[Música]
[Aplausos]
si yo les pregunto cómo creen que será
su vida dentro de 20 años
cuál será su respuesta
quizá muchos de ustedes me digan que no
tienen la más mínima idea
tal vez otros estén pensando en la
seguridad laboral económica y familiar
aquí no le gustaría tener a su familia
siempre a un lado
y quizás pocos menos o tal vez nadie se
imaginó en que ese día jamás llegue a
suceder
que el día de mañana por alguna extraña
razón dejemos de existir sin motivo
aparente
o que saliendo de aquí algo me suceda y
ese futuro inexistente e incierto
desaparezca de una vez por todas
esta reflexión a mí me hizo pensar y
soñar soñar y viajar y tal vez algunos
de ustedes no les guste mucho la idea de
dejarlo todo para viajar pero para mí es
la mejor forma y la más divertida de
encontrar diferentes versiones de mí
para mejorar las claras
dicen que algunas personas dicen que un
sueño se vive 33 veces
cuando se sueña cuando se vive y cuando
se recuerda ahora yo les puedo decir que
creo que son cuatro
las soñamos lo planeamos lo vivimos y lo
recordamos
y es que cuando yo sueño con hacer un
viaje vienen a mi cabeza todas esas
imágenes de los lugares que podía
conocer de la gente que me podría
encontrar en el camino de los olores y
los sabores que van a despertar a mi
mente a mis sentidos y no sé día de las
nuevas culturas que voy a conocer
dar el siguiente paso no es nada
sencillo
pensar en que voy a abandonar esa vida
que ya hice o se está formando a penas
es complicado
y quizá cuando pensemos en planear un
viaje lo primero que pensamos es un
sistema capital aprendido que nos lleve
a imaginar hoteles de lujo todo incluido
tarjetas de crédito buenos restaurantes
centros comerciales
y es que cuando yo estaba pensando en
planear mi viaje sabía que tenía que
olvidar ciertos conceptos que tenía
aprendidos
así que investigan y con algunas
recomendaciones encontré algunas páginas
web y algunas aplicaciones en donde
había lugares y personas que te
ofertaban comida y hospedaje a cambio de
unas pocas horas de trabajo al día lo
cual a mí me pareció increíble porque
además aprendería cosas nuevas cosas que
nunca había hecho en la vida
y otras personas más en otras
aplicaciones de viajeros que ofrecen sus
casas como refugios
si tuve que quitarme todas esas imágenes
de películas en donde todo termina en
tragedia supongo que las han visto y
tienen esas imágenes además
después de olvidar todas esas creencias
que yo tenía decidí en ponerme en
contacto con ellos
cuando estaba en esta etapa de
planeación se volvió un poco más
complejo porque dentro de mí ocurrían
muchísimas cosas era como una batalla
entre mis pensamientos contra mis
emociones y si le agregamos además las
expectativas que tienen los demás sobre
mí y mis propias expectativas de vida
es una lucha constante y comencé a
sentir mucho miedo mucha ansiedad mucha
frustración de no poder tomar una
decisión inmediata
y también de no saber qué es lo que me
esperaba más adelante
así que yo le dejé la decisión a mi
curiosidad
aquella curiosidad que me dice que
siempre hay algo mejor por venir
de lo que no sé que hay más allá
dicen que la curiosidad mató al gato
pero a mí me llevó a viajar esto ocurrió
hace un año atrás
así que tome todo lo que creí que me
haría falta en ese momento y lo que
tiene mochila de viaje
mi viaje comenzaría por las rutas
argentinas que me llevarían hasta el fin
del mundo
aquí me conectaría con la zona austral
de chile en ese lugar me esperaría mi
primer trabajo como voluntaria
ahora mi huerta se había convertido en
una huerta orgánica mi oficina quien no
quisiera tener una oficina como esté
rodeada de grandes montañas nevadas con
lagos ríos y cascadas provenientes del
hielo patagónico del sur
fascinante
aquí también comenzaría mi viaje de
aprendizaje aquí me daría cuenta que no
todos los conceptos se aprenden de un
libro que también a veces hay que salir
para despertar a nuestra mente viajera y
aprender cosas nuevas
después vendrían otros trabajos más
vendría un lugar una pequeña ciudad
muy al estilo suizo
aquí mi trabajo era recibir a viajeros
de todo el mundo y darles el mejor trato
posible
que otro mejor sería en el que a mí me
hubiera gustado que me dieran
después vendría a otro lugar más
donde los caminos y las carreteras no
están hechas de asfalto sino de agua
proveniente del río paraná
y por último como no mencionarles esa
gran hacienda a los pies de las montañas
del gran imperio inca
en estos lugares aprende a compartir mi
tiempo y mi espacio con una o con
muchísimas más personas a veces éramos
hasta 15 personas en un solo espacio
imagínense
con ellos también aprendería sobre
bioconstrucción plomería carpintería
vender helados infinidad de cosas pero
sobre todo y aunque nuestro trabajo no
era el mejor de todo
dábamos siempre lo mejor de nosotros
al final nos sobra muchísimo tiempo y
nos quedaba mucho espacio para nadar
reir jugar cantar bailar volar
así hasta llegar al silencio
un silencio que duraría diez días
esto me llevó a un lugar únicamente para
meditar
donde mis días comenzaban con el oscuro
antes del amanecer y con una brisa que
anunciaba la salida del sol
y media terminaba con un campo repleto
de luciérnagas y con el canto de los
grillos que armonizaban al unísono del
sonido
después de vivir esta experiencia no
tenía nada más que decir
veía como mis creencias y mis
pensamientos más arraigados
se iban diluyendo
yo no era la misma persona que había
salido un año a un año atrás con su
mochila a cuestas
me estaba transformando
y es que neurocientíficos afirman que
una vez que llevamos un cambio en
nuestras vidas la que sea no es
necesario que sea un viaje puede ser el
que ustedes más les guste aunque el
viaje es más divertido
nuestras nuestro cerebro comienza a
crear nuevos caminos entre neuronas
éstas se comunican mucho mejor es como
un camino que se forma en la montaña con
el diario pasar de un campesino con su
rebaño
estos nuevos caminos formados en nuestro
cerebro una vez que ya están hechos a
través de la práctica y la experiencia
se pueden renovar durante toda nuestra
vida
rubén forest stein lo llama aprender a
aprender dice que una vez que nosotros
hemos hecho un cambio en nuestra vida
puede transformar toda nuestra
estructura y que una vez que se ha
aprendido un concepto o algo diferente
podemos llevarlo a cabo las veces que
sean necesarias
que puede ser un aprendizaje duradero
e infinito
tan sencillo como mezclarlo todo en un
mismo lugar
mezclamos nuestras creencias nuestros
valores nuestra cultura nuestros
aprendizajes
y le agregamos algo completamente
diferente
y otras culturas otros valores otros
aprendizajes nuevos sabores esto es como
cuando nos vamos de viaje que a veces
nos cuesta complementarlo o llenarlo
directamente a nuestro mapa de creencias
así es como se va a ver completamente
separado
[Música]
a veces nos cuesta un poquito mezclar lo
que estamos aprendiendo
a esto no nos olvidemos mezclarle un
toque de color
el color que más les guste o el que
mejor ilumine ese momento que ustedes
están viviendo en este momento de sus
vidas
por último falta ese toque efervescente
ese que nos va a hacer movernos del
lugar en donde estamos
y así es como se va a ver cómo se
transforma todo dentro de nosotros todo
esto ocurre dentro de nuestro cerebro
toda esta movilidad es la que tenemos en
mente en nuestro interior nuestras
culturas nuestros pensamientos nuestros
valores pueden ir transformándose dentro
de nosotros
increíble no
yo pude haberme quedado en el lugar en
donde estaba con los mismos aprendizajes
de toda la vida
pude haber elegido distintos caminos o
diferentes
elegí viajar
a mí me gusta y me apasiona
durante este viaje he vivido historias
fascinantes las he contado me las han
contado la ser vista a través de la
mirada de otros las he vivido yendo de
la mano de alguien más
he visto y escuchado cosas que me han
hecho cuestionarme sobre distintos temas
además conocí gente que me abrió las
puertas de su vida sin pedir nada a
cambio
yo les pregunto a ustedes
por qué no
tropezarnos con distintas miradas
porque no ir a lugares
que deconstruye nuestros pensamientos y
transforme nuestro mundo
para que quedarnos en el lugar en donde
estamos
como dijo marcel proust porque el
verdadero cambio el verdadero viaje de
transformación no está en encontrar
nuevos caminos sino en tener nuevos ojos
buen viaje gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]